smite is where it all began for a lot of
us and having the opportunity to create
a new world for our fans that expands
the smite universe beyond a MOBA and
into an entirely new experience on
mobile is one of the coolest projects
anyone can ask well you have the
traditional smite conquest map with its
three lanes we decided to port that over
to our mobile game and that is
influenced you know our core designs
smite rivals is a collectible card arena
inside of it you battle against
opponents one-on-one in three lane
combat you build a deck with a God and a
series of minions structures and spells
and you use them to defeat your opponent
and try to destroy their base we look
for the actions that the players enjoyed
most in smite and created movesets that
capture that big godlike feel we had to
capture visuals and audio that really
stood out and made your device feel like
it was exploding with some sort of power
one of my favorite features of rivals is
that you can play anywhere you can play
from your phone or from a PC or tablet
and your progress saves across all three
of the devices if you're out with your
friends and you guys want to do a quick
match and show each other's new decks
and then go home and you know hop into a
different game mode and you can totally
do that if you look at all the games of
high-res release they're all free to fly
we want to make sure rivals been in that
same category so that means smite rivals
is going to be free-to-play on mobile
and PC before I had a chance to start
working on some my tribals I was already
a big fan of smite getting the
opportunity to work on this project and
kind of capture everything that I love
about smite has just been an absolute
pleasure we want to make sure that
rivals wasn't just a cool game but we
actually reward smite fans who
downloaded it so there'll be
cross-promotion content inside of smite
that you can get including exclusive
scans and other great collectibles it's
been a blast working on this game and
trying to capture the smite feel I'm
excited to see how the fanbase feels
about the gods that we've put in the
game and I can't wait to see and hear
their feedback playing the game was
definitely awesome everything just kind
of brings you in and it's just
interesting to look at it this is a good
looking game rivals has really been a
passion project for me and everybody
who's worked on it and we're excited to
share with the rest of the world in
early
17